sauf si vous vous rendez en espagne
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
les sorties de france par la route se
passe plutôt bien pour l'instant
et si justement vous vous rendez à
l'étranger vous devez avoir pris un
certain nombre de précautions
savez-vous exactement comment vous êtes
assurés en cas d'accident de france
qu'il s'agisse de votre automobile ou de
vous même en cas d'accident ou de
maladie
des professionnels de l'assurance et de
la sécurité sociale nous donne un
certain nombre d'informations un
accident à l'étranger voilà une
éventualité qui n'a rien d'impossible
premières précautions à prendre avant de
partir en vacances au delà de nos
frontières
s'assurer que le contrat d'assurance
souscrit couvre bien tous les risques
possibles
mais quelles sont ces risques les mêmes
que ceux que vous courez en france bien
sûr
auxquels s'ajoutent pourtant les
complications dues à la législation
locale et au fait que pour les autorités
du pays où vous vous trouvez vous n'êtes
pas un automobiliste comme les autres
sans parler de méfiance on peut dire que
tout est renwez fait courir un risque
supplémentaire en se rendant responsable
d'un accident et en repassant la
frontière le lendemain la première
preuve de garanties que vous devez
fournir
c'est évidemment la carte verte document
international
elle atteste que vous êtes bien assuré
dans le pays où vous vous trouvez mais
attention elle n'est pas valable partout
certains pays n'ont pas signé d'accord
et par conséquent la carte verte n'est
pas valable dans ces pays tels l'algérie
par exemple
et alors que doit faire une
automobiliste qui se rend dans un pays
où la couverture carte verte n'existe
pas alors il a 2 solutions ou et
souscrit un contrat d'assurance avant de
partir à l'étranger
il peut aussi souscrire à la frontière
une assurance qu'on appelle assurances
frontières le meilleur moyen pour les
autorités d'un pays dans lequel vous
êtes concerné par un accident qu'il soit
de la circulation de tout autre genre
c'est d'exiger de vous le versement
d'une caution mais bien rares sont les
touristes qui peuvent acquitter sur le
champ une somme qui n'est jamais
inférieure à dix mille francs même quand
on vous promet de vous la rendre si
votre bonne foi est démontré dans
certains pays il doit fournir une
caution s'il a causé un accident qu'il
veut sortir des frontières
d'où la nécessité pour lui d'avoir avant
de partir souscrit une assurance caution
par exemple pour l'espagne et pour les
pays de l'est
en particulier cette caution couvre quoi
en fait cette caution couvre les sommes
qui seront réclamés par les autorités
afin de permettre à l'automobiliste de
quitter les frontières
le contrat que l'on souscrit auprès
d'une société d'assurance vous garantis
pour votre responsabilité
mais il ne vous couvre pas vous même ni
vous ni votre famille ni votre véhicule
vous pouvez donc avoir intérêt à
souscrire un contrat voyages à
l'étranger
vous pourrez choisir des garanties
multiples des garanties de rapatriement
en cas d'accident ou des garanties
d'hospitalisation remboursement de frais
pharmaceutiques ou d'hôpital carte verte
caution contraint complémentaires sont
les particularités du voyage à
l'étranger
ça fait pourtant cela vous est plus
familier que le constat amiable à
couverture bleue peut être utilisé en
france bien sûr mais aussi en allemagne
fédérale en autriche en belgique aux
pays bas et au luxembourg
pour le reste soyez prudents et observez
bien les attitudes des conducteurs du
pays que vous visitez elle ne manque pas
parfois d'être curieuse que par exemple
pour la roumanie
le ministère des affaires étrangères a
signalé qu'il existait certains usages
qui risque de heurter l'automobiliste
français en particulier
la priorité est donnée à gauche dans les
carrefour à sens giratoire la
signalisation est faible ou inexistante
et paraît-il en cas de changement de
direction
les automobilistes romain signale ce
changement de direction en ouvrant la
portière gauche ou la portière de droite
ces conseils ne peuvent évidemment pas
prévenir tous les aléas du voyage à
l'étranger
mais il n'ya pas que l'accident il ya
aussi la maladie la sécurité sociale a
prévu cette éventualité
examinons tout d'abord le cas des pays
du marché commun
je conseillerais aux assurés sociaux qui
partent en allemagne ou dans des pays du
marché commun également en autriche et -
l'angleterre - là grande-bretagne leur
conseillerais de se rendre quelques
jours
avant de partir en vacances dans les
centres de paiement habituel dans ce
centre de paiement
le guichetier établira à l'attention de
l'assuré social un formulaire que l'on
appelle le formulaire e111 et ce
formulaire servira dans le pays dans
lequel il se rendra de bénéficier de la
sig raid et sociale du pays d'origine
sans avoir à débourser les frais sans
avoir à faire l'avancé
alors que se passe-t-il lorsqu'on se
trouve beaucoup plus loin hors d'europe
non ils n'ont pas de formalités à
remplir avant de partir en vacances mais
nous leur conseillons ardemment de
garder précieusement l'ensemble des
documents qui peuvent recevoir à savoir
les honoraires médicaux les honoraires
de médecins les factures acquittées et
cetera afin au corps autour de leurs
vacances de présenter l'ensemble de ce
dossier médical et de le remettre au
centre de paiement s'assurer contre tous
les risques courus pendant les vacances
n'est pas une précaution superflu c'est
au contraire partir avec l'esprit libre
et acquérir la certitude de ne pas se
créer d'ennuis facilement évitables
pourvu qu'on y pense avant